how many more questions you have two
more okay go
ahead uh all right um The One S 15
report I want to ask about it like uh is
it morally okay for God to to tell like
people to may like is it morally okay or
not how do you know what's moral or not
moral where you getting it from
um I mean if you're an atheist I don't
think that you have morals but so now as
a theist where do you get your morality
I don't know so when I first ask you
okay when you say is it moral or immoral
I want to know what's your standard what
are you appealing
to to know whether something's moral or
not I mean I guess you take your
morality from the Bible but I don't have
so now this is where you confuse me if
God who is the author of Life the owner
of Life tells you these children put to
death but you say it's immoral that
means it's no longer God who's the
standard or at least the Bible you're
appealing to some other standard what
other standard are you appealing to to
then determine this is
immoral all right so I cannot say that
it's immoral right you're right okay but
now to answer your question yeah when
you look at the and I've done you know
how many series I did I just did this
several Muslim I answer when you look at
the Bible as a
whole even if we take for granted that
there were
children okay you do not have what they
call a
temporal perspective of life meaning
you're not a materialist you're not a
naturalist who thinks that this is the
only life you have and if you die that's
it right right so let me show you from
God's perspective okay now what if God
knowing what you do not know that these
children grow up to be just like their
parents because why if you read the
stories each generation continued in the
filth and the sin of the generation
before the Canaanites right he waited
400 years it says so after waiting 4
years did any of them change their ways
or they continue in the filth immorality
murder incest of the generation before
them they continued in doing that they
didn't stop now put yourself in God's
perspective what if God knowing what you
don't
know these children will grow up to
continue to spread the garine the cancer
the disease of sin continue committing
incest continue slaughtering children to
mik because if you didn't know this the
Canaanites and archaeology confirmed it
they would have a statue of mik or hand
stretched out and they would ignite the
arms torching hot and would put a baby
on it and Scorch the baby to death a
light baby in sacrifice the
mik okay with me there yeah yeah I'm
with you all right so with me now now by
the way Ortho Christus it's recorded so
he's going to go back rewatch and it to
become second nature so generation after
generation those children grow up to be
like that incest sleeping with parents
with siblings you name it the nine yards
and God says enough I'm not going to cut
off the cancer the garine from spreading
so it doesn't corrupt the
rest of the geography so I'm going to
end this line of people by having the
children being put to to stop this
wicked evil immorality would God be
justified he would be if he I mean yeah
sure all right well no think about it
don't just say sure if every child grows
up to be just as wicked as their parents
and he knows what you don't
know God knowing what you don't know
says put an end to this now put the
children to death because they're going
to con continue and I want to cut off
the cancer the Garing to stop it from
spreading spiritual cancer spiritual
gang because sin is described as
sickness and disease would God be
justified he would be but what happens
to the babies like do they go to heaven
immediately well you gota wait
brother you're jumping
ahead so would he be justified he would
be yeah sure would he be justified if he
killed Hitler as a
baby I mean it's the same thing yeah
because I'm just saying yeah sure he
would but then when he lets a Hitler
live then you blame God for allowing
Hitler to live so what do you want God
to
do I was going to actually ask you about
Hitler the example of H because I know
you're dumb so I already answered it so
what allows Hitler to exist and then
kill Millions you say why God but if I
killed Hitler as a baby you're gonna say
why God so I don't win with
you so make up your mind what do you
want God to
do I don't know yeah exactly in other
words God saying shut up let me be God
let
me
right yeah sure telling you can you shut
up let me run it because you don't know
what I know I let Hitler live to show
you the evil that a human being can do
but then you get angry that I let him
live but if I killed him as infant but
he was an infant he was such a cute
baby you know what God is telling you
you have a three-pound brain it's
already damaged as it
is can you shut up and let me I'm God I
have an infinite mind I know what you
don't know let me do it let me handle it
I'm in control now coming back go ahead
how did you know that I was going to
give the example of fitler because I'm
not as dumb as you
look right now can we go back to the
second part now according to the Bible
if you read it carefully carefully and
I've done sessions on this children who
do not know between right and wrong who
do not know about their moral
responsibility who are not aware of God
they die and under God's eyes in a state
of Innocence they're under the grace of
God so the saving benefits of Jesus are
applied to them so though their life
ends here their life begins with Jesus
forever and
ever so it's win-win isn't
it in that case yeah it is that's what
the Bible says what do you mean yeah
that Jesus says the king belongs to such
children so if you let God be God he has
the
answer if you let God be God he has the
answer and that's why many times he
spared Nations for the sake of the
children who do not know any better here
Jonah 411 when when Jonah was upset that
my ancestors because Nineveh was the
capital of the Assyrian Empire I'm
Assyrian son of Asher not Syrian caldan
Assan were the same people even though
the Bible scribes changed it it was
actually Cala the king of Calia they
changed it to Syria see that calans
these Assyrian haters anyway God
spared the
Assyrians here's why look and the king
of God belongs to who let's
see here you go Jonah 411 he says to
Jonah you're upset that I did not
destroy the ninevites so should I not
have pity on Nineveh look you didn't
want me to pity Nineveh now remember
this is the god of Israel but look at
his love for all nations he loves the
Assyrians now by the way n Jonah
hated Jonah hated the Assyrians he
wanted them wiped out now take one good
look at me and you see
why see
that okay now let's finish it so should
I not have pity on Nineveh the great
City in which there are more than
120,000 persons who do not know the
difference between their right and left
hand as well as many animals you didn't
want me to spare the city when there's
more than 120,000 people who do not know
any better now by sparing them
they will be raised in the fear of God
but even if he took them away then they
would be with him forever so God can
decide to spare the nation that
repents and their children if they
repent Nineveh repented Canaanites did
not
repent so if they repented the children
be spared but if they don't repent
they're wiped out and the children go to
heaven so it's a win-win situation right
yeah all right now Look Look what Jesus
says about the
Kingdom the kingdom belongs to who let's
see here you
go Matthew 1815 at that time disciples
came to J said who then is the greatest
in the kingdom of heaven and he called
the child to himself and set him before
them and said truly I say to you unless
you are converted and become like
children you will never enter the
kingdom of heaven you must become like a
child why whoever
therefore right will humble himself as a
child he is the greatest in the Kingdom
of Heaven whoever receives one such
child in my name receives me so the
kingdom belongs to
who I can't hear you
buddy oh sorry
uh the kingdom belongs
to I'm sorry I didn't hear you like I
don't know what happened so what part
did would you hear what was the last
part you heard you were saying something
about the
kingdom according to Matthew 1815 how do
I enter the kingdom he called a child to
himself
unless you convert become like children
you'll never enter the kingdom yeah you
should be a children to enter the
kingdom of the Kingdom belongs to who to
Jesus
to the kingdom belongs
to to who it's in front of your eyes
brother not to like to Children you
should be a children to enter the
Kingdom so the kingdom belongs to who
the children
so then if children die where do they go
according to
Jesus to Heaven that means children no
matter if they're Palestinian Israeli no
matter if they're Iranian Iraqi
Hindu God doesn't consider children
Hindu or Muslim they are his children he
created them he loves them they and if
they die whether children die of cancer
or whatever it is they are under the
mercy of Jesus and the Lord applies his
saving death to them and brings them
into his presence that's why when you go
to heaven you're going to see millions
and millions of children who are from
Hindu backgrounds Buddhist backgrounds
you name it because to Jesus they're not
Hindu Buddhists they're his
creatures right and now right here
Matthew
1913-15 then some children were brought
to him so they might lay his hands on
them pray and that disciples rebuked him
but Jesus said let the children alone do
not hinder them for coming to me why for
the kingdom of them belongs to
what to these who's
these the children exactly yeah that
means the Canaanite children who did not
know any better they're with Jesus all
children who don't know any better and
they die the Lord Jesus saves them out
of his love and grace because he died
even to allow them the grace of being
with him forever that's why on my
Facebook page guess what picture I have
look at my
Facebook Jesus holding the hand of a
Palestinian and
Israeli
child because Jesus is not pro-israel
Jesus is not pro Palestine Jesus is the
king of creation the God of all creation
he's a God of all children he loves the
Palestine child as much as the Israeli
child he does not discriminate that
that's the Jesus I worship and
love that's the Jesus whom I worship and
love he doesn't look at him say you're
Palestinian get out of here or you're
Israeli Zionist get out no you are my
creation you are my creation I created
you for my glory and you are children of
my father and I've died to redeemed you
and now there'll be no hatred between
you because there is no Jew or inian
you're one in me this is Jesus